je sais qu'il fallait pour l'équipe pour
tous les sponsors conditions et puis a
présenté comme il fallait
le club et y voit là bas on était moins
difficile à les possédants et si on
n'avait pas vu le plus chiant on va s
appuie sur la chaîne s'était un peu
quand on arrive et si olivier pilote
savait qu'il fallait tout donner dans
les bascules juico tout ça c'est vrai on
se lavait n'avait secondes derrière
fallait tout donner pour garder mes bras
j'ai tout fait y avait la victoire
d'étape à ma portée je les laissais à et
d'une bulle comme je suis m'a aidé c'est
un jeu alors bon je laisse avec toi pour
lui je suis japonais le maillot jaune
alors il est le seul et unique objectif
ce sera très difficile
on va dire que je suis le seul leader
j'ai mes coéquipiers qui m'aident
commentaire bon allez fais ce qu'il faut
et voilà ces neuf jours neuf jours fous
d'afrique